welcome to the second lesson in native
language course on language change in
language history this time around we're
going to look at the kinds of concepts
we need to be familiar with in order to
evaluate whether or not two languages
are related and how they're related
how closely they're related the first
thing we need to consider is what part
of language are we going to be looking
at what part of a language are we going
to be comparing and through trial and
error it seems the best practice that's
been established is to look at what's
known as basic core vocabulary basic
core vocabulary is a range of words
vocabulary items that stand for common
concepts including family members
including basic concepts that are found
in nature animals pronouns very common
everyday items that at least in theory
aren't replaced very much and are passed
down to the next generation of speakers
early and often we'll also need to know
what to look for when we compare the
basic core vocabulary of one language to
another when we look at vocabulary items
which are just single words what we'll
find is that when two languages are
related they'll share a resemblance a
common root so the two vocabulary items
will ultimately derive from the same
common source we used the word common to
mean that at one time they were the same
but they diverged over time in different
areas in different speech communities
into distinct words in two different
languages but suffice it to say that
cognate is just a term for saying that
these two are related words that come
from some common ancestor that's what
we're looking for to establish a
relationship but that's not the only
reason that two words would look similar
to words might also look similar to each
other due to chance
in other words randomly over time
especially with small words and
languages will find that similar words
similar sounding words will stand for
similar concepts so we might find that
the word for water in one language
resembles the word in a completely
unrelated language and the two words may
not
be related at all when one language
comes into contact with another language
it often borrows words from that other
language it takes words especially for
concepts that it doesn't already have
for example in English we borrow the
word cafe from French cafe the two words
aren't genuine cognates that developed
independently in English and French
rather English speakers at some point
borrowed the word cafe from French the
same analysis helps us when we look at
the basic core vocabulary list of
English we have a word person the word
person is a fairly basic word yet it was
actually borrowed it's not a native
dramatic word in English well it's a
native word now but it was at some point
borrowed into English so when we find
languages like Spanish Italian and
French that inherited this word from
Latin we can't genuinely say let's
compare the English cognate to the
French cognate or the English cognate to
the Spanish cognate because at some
point English borrowed that word whereas
the other languages inherited it at this
point you have some understanding of
cognates in language and an
understanding of similarities that will
show up due to things other than
cognates namely borrowing and chance now
we'll be able to move on and compare
individual languages and start to look
at family relationships